This is something I've always wanted to ask you about,
and I'm excited to ask you about it since I've gotten to know you a bit and
now's maybe a good time. Um, cause I,
I heard you on a podcast a while back when, when you were first, um,
campaigning for president and,
and you were talking about universal basic income,
but then you were also saying like,
and you could don't wanna put words in your mouth.
You could express this better than I could,
but you were talking about like having other programs and structures to
support kind of productivity and like
community driven collaborative efforts,
whether it's an art or in other fields that were not
necessarily driven by a commercial market, but,
um, but we're driven by other modes of Oh yeah. Yeah.
I'm so interested in, in how that works,
because I don't know that commerce is the only way to drive art.
Yeah. Thank you for calling that out. Uh,
so that, to me,
the pillar number one is like put money into people's hands.
Would folks have more freedom to create? Yes.
Would they have more ability to reward artists and creators? Yes.
If you had better structures in place, uh,
but there's like this whole set of activities that, uh,
has been eroding for years and decades in the United States of America that we,
I think most of us agree are like pretty positive stuff that the market just is
not going to love. And one thing that let you know, I use as an example,
when I travel is like local papers, local newspapers,
local newspapers are getting wiped out like a, you know,
a thousand local papers gone and democracy does not function as well if you
don't have local papers. Uh, so let's,
let's say even if we had more money in the community, sure.
Some more local papers would survive,
but maybe you decide that local journalism is good regardless of whether or not
like the advertising makes money or, you know, like the, the subscriptions.
And so if you start looking at some things that maybe we can agree are positive,
which I would definitely put art in this category,
I'd put local journalism in this category.
I put volunteering for a civic organization, um,
in this category. And so volunteerism is down, uh,
like pretty much anything where like that there's something that you regard as
positive in the community, um, has been declining by the numbers for years.
And so there's like this whole suite of activities where I don't think any of us
necessarily wants to get quote unquote paid for everything. It's like, Hey,
if I, you know, volunteer for the non-profit like, non-profit pay me. It's like,
there has to be like some sort of activity you do. That's like non-monetary,
but also, um, something that we,
we want to reward or reinforce.
And so my idea was essentially you create like a parallel economy
around this other set of activities that could,
that we could use another currency for or time. Um,
and it was based on something called time banking where, um,
in the sixties RFKs speech writer was trying to figure out how to help. Um,
poor communities become more socially connected.
And what they came up with was something called TimeBanking where if I babysit
your kids,
then you get me back by hauling like logs off my lawn.
And we essentially just trade like units of time with each other. Um,
and so you could introduce like a different currency or time units into this
other set of activities that we know we need more of,
but you don't want to pay people for, cause it's like a little messed up.
So,
and I would certainly put art in this category where if someone produces public
art, uh, then they would get, uh, you know,
this other currency reward or other people get them back in
various ways. It'd be a way to try and stitch together, uh, social interactions.
Uh, and, and,
and also you could disclose it publicly in a way that you don't money.
So if I'm like, Hey, I made a thousand bucks, like I'm an.
If I'm like waving around like my thousand dollars my head,
but it, but if I got these like, you know, um,
a thousand, um, social points,
so whatever you call them, um,
then you could actually broadcast it in a way that everyone finds perfectly
socially acceptable. Um,
and then you could even give those social points to someone else. Um, and, uh,
and then they could use it for various things.
So that was like the thinking around like, uh, like you,
you need something non-monetary for certain activities that you
want to help see more of.
Can I ask you more about how that will work?
I know you haven't like fleshed it out entirely.
So this is maybe just a totally hypothetical situation,
but I just find that so fascinating. I want to ask you more about like,
so in the case of an artist, say,
cause that's obviously what's close to my heart and experience.
So someone who,
who makes some art say they make a, a song,
they record a song and it's,
it's not necessarily like the kind of commercially viable song that a
record label is going to invest in or something, but they,
they have the potential to earn this sort of whether it's like time,
time banking or social points or whatever you call it, how there,
there would have to be what,
some kind of system in place that would determine whether w how many social
points that song is worth, or like, how would that kind of.
So the, my thinking on this,
and this is actually very close to the conversation I was having with the
musicians online, um, would be that if I listened to the song,
just by virtue of my listening to the song, you get like a social credit, uh,
uh, for the fact that I listened to it,
it's like essentially a micropayment thing.
Oh God. Okay. So everybody who listens to it than that. Right. Okay.
So it does have to do with, um,
the audience that you garner for art that you create. Yeah.
Right. But so, cause right now, the way that you can make money
or to get any kind of compensation for that sort of thing is say,
you put your song on YouTube, but your video on YouTube or whatever,
and YouTube is able to, if,
if a million or more people come and watch your video,
you might make enough money on ads that they'll give you like a few bucks. Um.
This is the distinction you drew initially. Um, Joseph,
cause I've been struggling with how the heck we got,
we would get this done on a societal level.
You essentially want the world to look more like Netflix than YouTube.
Right. It's like.
Where we're paying, but in this case you don't necessarily want.
And I think like tier one,
which would be better is if we all had money and we're all paying for stuff.
Um, but then tier two would be like, Hey, I'm paying with my attention.
And you can take like this attention currency and use that for various things
to, um, some of which it could be monetary, um,
because you want to try and get the like, cause right,
right now people are conditioned to consume our content for free or near free.
Um, and then you pay it, then you pay a subscription and then you're like, okay,
now I'm in the walled garden. And I get like the cool,
like a movie or TV show from like the, the Joseph [inaudible] of the world.
And so what you want to do is you want to create like,
like closer to that walled garden dynamic, um, out there,
like a way where if you pay attention to something,
then the creator is getting rewarded. Um,
and it doesn't necessarily necessitate my whipping out my credit card.
Right, right. Cause someone has spent their time on your art.
So if it were time banking, it would be that, that kind of thing. Yeah.
And so like the, the time actually has value. Um, and then it,
and then if people have elected to spend their time on your art,
then you actually like build up this time currency that you, you know,
you could trade for dollars. Like, you know,
there could be like an exchange rate essentially.
Right. So, and in order for that to happen, it would just,
it would have to be kind of top down, right?
Like the government would have to say, okay,
there is the government is just like the government does with dollars.
Like dollars is a top-down thing. The government says we do United States.
Government is deciding that us dollars are valuable. Right. And,
and so you're saying that like the government would have to say,
we're also saying now that time is valuable and here is a like
government built structure,
like institution for how we can exchange time
currency.
So here's where it gets interesting.
That TimeBanking is an effect right now in hundreds of communities around the
country like that, they're just doing it informally. They have some ledger,
they'll keep, keep, keep track of it. Um,
and there are also some apps, uh,
like there's one called civic stains of karma points.
There are different things where they're starting try and monitor this.
So if you were a foundation or a philanthropy or a billionaire or whatnot,
I know some of these characters, so this is an entirely hypothetically, like,
could you go in and say, Hey guys, guess what? Like, we're,
we're going to essentially guarantee your time currency at like a certain
exchange. Um, and, uh, so if you do something for someone, you develop it,
you know, you get,
get a credit or you produce public art and people want to reward it. Um,
and then if you want, like,
we've got like essentially like an exchange bank and I'm going to monetize it to
the tune of a million bucks, 10 million bucks, whatever it is. Uh, and, and the,
the fun thing about this is that you could potentially create like,
like a hundred million worth of, uh,
interactions or social activity with like a much smaller level of money. Um,
but you would need to essentially do it within a community the same way that
communities are doing it with time banking. Right now.
I agree with you on a macro level, you'd probably need the government, uh,
lending a hand, like if you wanted to do it,
like throughout the entire us economy, and you were dealing with like massive,
um, numbers, but you could pilot this in a community, um,
certainly in terms of in-person activities and it's happening now. Uh,
and then the trickier thing, which is something that I,
I genuinely think that we need to be investing a ton of energy and
resources on is how to make it happen in the digital universe is how to make it
so that like a, your time is actually, uh,
monetizeable in a different way than advertising,
because we have to face facts that right now, so much of our internet, uh,
enjoyment or whatever is based on advertising.
And there was a period when it seemed like, okay, this is cool. Like I've got a,
you know, free Facebook for YouTube free this. Um,
but now it's degenerated into this form of pernicious surveillance, capitalism
where they're like, and among other problems, it's absolute for creators.
Yes. Yeah. I think it really is. Uh, and, uh,
and it, it's not just, um,
it's not just the ads.
It's what comes with the ads.
Like you mentioned the difference between like a Netflix and a YouTube.
And again, I'm saying again, there's lots of great stuff on YouTube.
I love YouTube.
I look at YouTube all the time and I find amazing things that I never would have
been able to find anywhere else. Like YouTube is incredible, but there,
there is a difference between what YouTube will recommend
versus what Netflix will recommend,
because there's a difference between how they're monetizing the viewers that
Netflix is trying to serve viewers,
something that's so good and meaningful to them that they're willing to
pay out of their pocket for it.
Whereas YouTube is trying to serve up things that are just going to like catch
your attention and keep your attention. And it doesn't have to be,
it doesn't to be so profound or meaningful that you would pay money for it.
That doesn't,
it doesn't have to be that it just has to kind of catch you enough to keep your
attention. And those are two different offerings that are,
that are a result of those two different models.
And I think like, as an artist, I,
I'm much more interested in making art,
not that's just going to catch someone's attention and kind of like hook them
and keep their attention. I'm interested in making stuff.
That's going to be really meaningful to somebody that they're going to think
about afterwards. It's going to, like, they're going to remember.
You create different, uh, work based upon one goal. And the other,
the other thing is that if you do succeed in catching someone's attention,
even for like X minutes, and then afterwards, you're like, okay, like,
what did I get? Like as the creator, I mean, right now, like, you know,
in many cases it's next to nothing or nothing. Um,
and then that doesn't create like an ecosystem that enables that artist to like,
do something else reinvest. So, you know, uh, like pay themselves,
have health care, like whatever, like the, um,
like one of the basics that we'd expect anyone who's working, um, you know,
creatively to have.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.